- We've got Amy Poehler with us!
Give it up!
So, in her show, "Making It".
Amy teams up with her friend Nick Offerman
to test the crafting and building skills
of contestants. In honor of that teamwork,
it's time for me and Amy
to team up for a game
we call "What's Creepin' Up On Me?"
(upbeat music)
- What's creepin' up on me?
- It's awesome.
- This is exciting.
- [Kelly] It's amazing, Jesse.
So you seem like you'd be a great teammate
for like a game night. Am I right?
- Thank you very much. And yes, yes, I am.
- Well, we're on the
same team in this game
so here's how it works.
Amy and I each have screens behind us.
We can't see what's in our
own screens, obviously.
So we'll give each other
clues about what's creeping
up without saying the name of the thing.
We can pass if one is too hard.
If we can correctly guess 10 things
in two rounds, the audience
will win a cool prize.
And if not Amy sucks, I was good.
Are you ready?
- Yeah, I'm ready. Okay. Here we go.
- [Kelly] Okay, wait, you're
going to give me a clues first.
Okay, so ready?
- I'm going to tell you
what's creepin up on you.
- Yes. Okay. Ready? Go.
- Okay. It's not an
octopus, but it's like that.
- A squid.
- Um, yes. Okay. The next
one is the opposite of God.
It's a bad force.
- Hell, Satan.
- Yes. Um, oh, I host the
Golden Globes with her.
- Oh, Tina Fey
- Yes. This is, this is great.
Okay. This is a primate doing
something that people do
- A gorilla
- Every day with their morning with their,
with their coffee. Yes. So it's
- A gorilla pooping?
Or, with morning coffee?
Constitution. What are you talking about
- Think? Smaller than a gorilla.
- A monkey?
- Yes. Okay. We're moving on next.
Okay. This is you hop on
to go around New York City.
- Subway
- You know the EL.
- Subway. I said subway.
- The one, the nine, the N, the R.
- I said subway.
- It's underground.
- She can't hear me, I said subway.
- Okay, okay, this is
the symbol for America.
- Our flag. The American flag. Eagle!
- No, We have, we moved
on to the next one?
We're still, there's still.
(horn sounds)
- That means, oh, okay, that we are done.
How many did I get right?
I got six right.
Okay. That means, okay,
here, I'm moving over here.
That means that we need to get four more
for the audience to win.
Are you ready?
I'm giving you clues.
- Never been more ready?
- Okay. Let's do this. Go!
There in that, if they sting you,
they say to pee on
yourself. If in the ocean.
- A jellyfish.
- Yes! I can't see who it is.
Oh, ha ha ha, that guy, liar liar.
- Jim Carrey.
- Yes! I couldn't think of a think he did.
Oh, this is also something
in the grass, like
from the garden of Eden.
- Snake.
- Okay, and then this is, what is that?
Oh, it's like, kids like these
things and they're in sand
in their rooms, tiny things
and lots of them crawl
in it and they build
- Oh, like an ant farm?
(horn sounds multiple times)
- Wow, yes! We did it.
- [Amy] We did it.
- Okay. We're amazing. That means everyone
in the audience is a big winner.
All right, everybody, Amy's
show is all about making crafts,
but crafting can make
you work up an appetite.
So you're all getting an
Emeril Lagasse Pasta & Beyond
pasta maker. Bew, bew, bewwww.
Enjoy fresh homemade pasta
at home in just minutes.
Plus, it doubles as a juicer
and frozen dessert maker,
which is awesome.
So you can make sorbet, frozen yogurt
and even gelato or possibly frozen drinks.
Just throwing it out there.
Thanks for playing Amy.
We were awesome.
And we should have a game night
- Anytime. Kelly, I love
you. Congratulations.
- Thank you! I love you so much.
Everybody y'all can see Making It tonight
on NBC and streaming tomorrow on Pacock.
Also, check Amy out in
Duncanville, new episodes
air Sundays on Fox.